where you cannot find me is watching the
super bowl i did not do it partially
this is my fault i'm just not a big
football fan more of a baseball guy i
know
i know it makes me like un-american or
something but you know that's usual
but but so part of it is my fault part
of it is the nfl's fault
uh you know part of the reason that i
didn't watch this year is uh
i just uh i wasn't very interested in
listening to woke slam poetry
i didn't want to watch these radical
left-wing commercials
you know tom brady seems like a great
athlete but all the
hullabaloo with the left-wing politics i
couldn't couldn't really get into it so
thankfully
i will be joined by one of our nation's
leading sports experts one of the most
prominent sports
journalists in america and the founder
of outkick
clay travis to help me break down the
super bowl clay thank you so much for
being here
appreciate you guys having me hope all's
going well oh it's it is going well
uh it's not going as well for us as it
is for tom brady who as far as i can
tell
is this greatest athlete to ever walk
the earth
however i was very confused by something
clay maybe you can you can help me
understand this
last night tom brady he gets his seventh
ring
he's just the the goat right he's the
greatest of all time everyone's
celebrating him and then i wake up this
morning
and colin kaepernick is trending
on twitter at last i checked colin
kaepernick did not play in the super
bowl
uh did not does not quite have the
record of a tom brady
why why are people promoting kaepernick
after the super bowl
it's just a sham show i mean look the
the twitter algorithms
are completely rigged let me just take a
step back
there are 45 million people who watch
the afc and the nfc championship games
uh that's a lot of people but when the
actual super bowl is played
a hundred million people watch wow so
there are over
55 million people usually on average
who care enough about the super bowl
but don't care enough about the final
four in the nfl and this is where
you know actual football fans get upset
about super bowl sunday because they're
surrounded by people
who haven't paid attention all season
long
and then suddenly parachute in and at
super bowl parties you know they're the
experts or they're the people who are
uh you know distracting from the game
itself and everything else associated
with it so
it has long been my contention and i
believe it's 100 true that the people
who insist on making colin kaepernick a
story
aren't actually sports fans right
they're the people who parachute in
and pretend to be sports fans like
sports fans aren't running around talk
they know colin kaepernick
was a mediocre at best starting
quarterback who had lost his job to
blame gabbard
and owes his relevance to non-sports
fans deciding that they want to trumpet
his constant
uh his constant relevance and so uh
uh you know i've gotten used to it and
i've been and i you know talk about this
every now and then
don't you just wake up and you find out
that you're trending you know and you're
like
i didn't say anything different than
what i've said for the last decade and
all of a sudden
i am you know rolling through and
everything is uh and everything's
trending so
i think this is the algorithm at work i
think it's people who are not sports
fans
sitting around and deciding to propagate
an idea which is totally
and completely not true uh which is that
uh that that colin kaepernick is in some
way worthy of discussion
in the larger nfl uh landscape right
it's both the algorithm specifically on
twitter
but i think your your view of it applies
more broadly there is this kind of
social algorithm
that is arranged by corporate america by
the bureaucracy
by big tech obviously by hollywood that
that
kind of warps reality right and so i i
agree you know
all of the actual nfl fans they're
focused on the game
but then all these kind of woke
political activists they're focused on a
guy like
colin kaepernick who as you say was a
mediocre quarterback
he lost his job it was spun that he was
horribly persecuted and as a result of
this horrible
political persecution he's made what
tens of millions of dollars
as a nike spokesman if only please if
only i could be so persecuted
as a colin kaepernick there was there
was another uh person who was trending
today too
i think for similar kinds of political
reasons
serena williams very talented
women's tennis player uh she was
trending i saw a lot of
people talking about her because they
said tom brady
is not the greatest of all time actually
if you want to talk about greatest
athlete of all time
that would be serena williams and i know
i know i'm not allowed to say this
because it's politically incorrect and
i'm probably you know i'm going to
get cancelled or something correct me if
i'm wrong i'm not a sports expert
it is simply not the case that
serena williams is a better athlete than
tom brady am i wrong am i crazy have i
transgressed and said something
unacceptable
no look uh men are bigger stronger and
faster than women
i mean this is a biological certainty so
uh
you know this that we had this
controversy a few years ago when john
mcenroe
uh was was criticized for saying sereno
wouldn't be one of the 700
best male tennis players and people were
like aghast that he would say such a
thing
i mean serena williams is a great
women's tennis player
uh you know what i did in in my
distinction
uh and again this is identity politics
driven with serena williams but
uh what i did is i said look you can't
really compare
individual sport athletes with team
sport athletes
if you're truly being fair right so my
radio show this morning i said look i
think you have to take away
the serena williams the roger federer
the
uh rafael nadal the uh martina
navratilova
the the the the the swimmers the michael
phelpses of the world
uh the the great sprinters like usain
bolt
those are sport athletes and so
you can't really compare them with team
sport athletes
so to me the the more interesting by far
conversation about tom brady is
where does he bring in the larger
lineage of great team sport athletes and
i think with his seventh super bowl
it's he or jordan in fact and i don't
have the poll in front of me right now
uh but i put up a poll this morning and
said who is the greatest american team
sport athlete of all time uh
with jordan and brady as two options and
then
other because inevitably some people
decide that they're gonna
they want to add a third person into the
mix or a fourth person or whoever it
might be
but that's the only fair way i think you
can assess because otherwise
how do you how do you figure out a team
sport athlete compared to
an individual athlete it's hard to
compare boxers and swimmers
right with football players or
basketball players no i think that makes
a lot of sense and
that does clear it up a little but it
does bring up the question of
brady as an individual because even i
who you know i really barely watch any
football all year
but when when brady announces he's
leaving the patriots and going to
another team sort of shocked oh my gosh
you know guys should retire uh patriot
that's so
that's so crazy and then what happens he
takes that team
all the way to the top does this does
this settle the debate
over you know what accounted for the
patriots success all those years you
know is it the coaching is it the
management is it
is it the players i mean can we now say
yeah it was tom brady
yeah i think we can and uh the data if
you want to
consider it is uh in his entirety of his
career and bill belichick has coached a
lot of games believe it or not
without tom brady he's won 46
of his nfl games without tom brady with
tom brady bill belichick has won
77 of his game so that's a pretty
seismic difference
and uh i think you can look at what the
impact was for brady not even
necessarily on the patriots although
they did go
from making the playoffs to seven and
nine without him
but in taking the uh tampa bay
buccaneers from
seven and nine to fifteen and five
and winning a uh winning a super bowl
the only big difference that was uh in
that team
was tom brady at quarterback and so i
always say for people out there who are
football fans
the quarterback matters the most in the
nfl the coach matters the most
in college football and uh and i believe
that to be uh pretty much fundamentally
true
and certainly brady has uh struck a big
blow
towards demonstrating that he is the
reason for the patriot
uh dynasty much more so than belichick
with this
season's results yeah there were a lot
of people last night after the win who
were saying all right we need to have a
wellness check on bill belichick
yeah so really really tough uh because
brady just
so so showed his worth last night
do you think i noticed a lot of uh hate
going around
for tom brady as well and some people
are saying this is political
because you know brady was friends with
trump he seems like a little bit more
a little bit more right wing than most
people you know he wasn't wearing the
mask i don't know
he probably still would have won the
super bowl even if he was wearing a mask
but he wasn't wearing the mask very
politically incorrect do you think that
the brady hate
is driven by politics or do you think
like look i'm a i'm a new yorker i'm a
yankee fan
everyone always hated the yankees in the
90s and i don't think they hated him
over politics i think they hated them
because they won
you know there is a thing in sports you
just kind of
the winners engender a lot of envy and
hatred what do you think it is do you
think it's the politics or do you think
it's just because the guy's so good
i think it's a little bit of everything
i think when you are a
big figure like tom brady is there are a
lot of reasons why people choose not to
like you
and i can tick off probably three or
four one the patriots always seem to be
uh playing on the edge they weren't just
a successful team
they had the tape issue where they taped
their walkthrough they had
the deflate gate issue with tom brady
over the footballs and
whether or not they were violating rules
there and
the belichick era in general just seemed
seeped
in uh secrecy and he wasn't necessarily
a guy that you would particularly
trust a second factor i think is you had
to be a brady guy
or a manning guy and whereas peyton
manning kind of branded himself
as an everyman an awes guy the kind of
person who would go get his hair cut
uh at a ten dollar barber and sometimes
look like it right he's not necessarily
a great looking guy
uh but that's kind of the everyman
appeal of peyton manning versus brady
who marries a victorious secret
supermodel uh
you know is incredibly good looking
himself uh
carries himself as sort of uh this cover
boy for gq
at all times most people can't really
relate to being that good looking
and that good at football too so i think
that kind of alienates him a little bit
and then i also think there is
an element of look uh bob crap robert
kraft the owner of the patriots bill
belichick
uh tom brady they all seem to have a
decent relationship
with donald trump now a lot of that was
from before
trump was ever a celebrity in any way in
terms of politics right it was from
pro-am circuits for golf and uh and
whatnot
before he ever became a professional
politician
uh but you know in the world that i am
that i live in
uh which is sports everybody has to hate
donald trump right you can't go to the
white house you have to consider him to
be the worst human being ever
and if you don't if you're a god forbid
actual adherent
then you've got a guy like kurt
schilling who isn't able to get inducted
into the hall of fame because of his
support for donald trump not because of
anything that he's done on the field
because if he were a
left-winger like kurt schilling would
have already been in the hall of fame so
this is just kind of i know we talk a
lot about the media in general being
left-leaning and i think that's accurate
the sports media is far more
left-leaning believe it or not
than the media as a whole in this
country uh and so
it's kind of crazy that that i think
brady occupies
all of those uh sort of regions where
people can choose to like or dislike
him right it's sort of sort of a perfect
storm it reminds me actually what
happened with a lot of rappers you know
before trump was ever in politics the
guy was famous for 30 years oh they
loved him
they loved him you know he was in all of
these kind of songs and then
you know trump becomes president all of
a sudden all these rappers
have to explain away all the parties
they went to and how how much they hung
out with the guy how much they liked him
so so uh you know where where do we go
from here because we've talked a lot
about brady and the game itself and all
but the the nfl you know the show
was uh pretty frustrating in terms of
the politics not just the commercials
but
i don't know the slam poetry thing i was
kind of weird and
uh i don't know it wasn't as bad as when
colin kaepernick started kneeling
however many
years ago that was but it did seem
overtly political
uh you know it kind of convinced me not
to go to a super bowl party and not to
watch
do you think the nfl is going to learn
any lessons you know we got about 30
seconds where do we go
first of all the nfl deserves credit for
actually playing their season when many
people in woke communities would have
said it's unsafe
uh i think the nfl unfortunately is a
reflection of corporate workocracy
where it's the advertisements are
effectively
all the show now right uh the woke sort
of uh
binning at the bending at the knee uh to
all the woke politics i actually think
that's gonna fade because i do think
it's bad for business
uh and i hope it's sooner rather than
later uh yeah i agree
i i agree and yeah a little a little
glimmer of hope i suppose
uh clay thank you so much for
enlightening me
a true rube when it comes to uh to the
super bowl
and all sports uh but pretty amazing
even you know even for someone like me
who doesn't really care
very very impressive game yesterday clay
travis go check out outkick yeah thank
you man go check out clay everywhere
he's so good